Transcriptor: Emma Davies
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hace 60 años, en mi infancia,
el sistema financiero costarricense
era un sistema muy simple.
Muy pocas personas
tenían acceso al sistema
y los pocos que tenían el acceso
lo que tenían era
una libreta de ahorro.
Básicamente ese era el sistema.
Hoy tenemos un sistema donde la relación
con el consumidor financiero
es mucho más profunda.
Tenemos muchísima
más inclusión financiera.
La gran mayoría de los costarricenses
tienen algún producto financiero
y además, son productos más sofisticados.
Y algunos de esos productos
son más bien productos de crédito,
lo cual lo hace mucho,
mucho más complejo.
Y estamos ahora en una sociedad
que es mucho más sofisticada.
Y entonces, entre se empiezan a gestar
temas y problemas
en esa relación entre
las entidades financieras
y los consumidores.
Y son cosas que nosotros
vivíamos día a día.
Por ejemplo, en un caso que me tocó vivir,
estábamos hablando en la asociación
bancaria con un funcionario público
y nos contó lo que le había pasado
con su tarjeta de crédito.
Resulta que obtuvo la tarjeta
y no sabía que tenía un seguro
que se pagaba contra la misma tarjeta.
Nunca la usó, nunca abrió
los estados de cuenta
y nunca se enteró
de que había algo que pagar
hasta que llegó a pedir
un crédito de vivienda
y se enteró que estaba este moroso.
Es un caso donde el diablo
está en los detalles,
donde hay un tema de información
que tienen que abordar tanto
las personas que usan el servicio
como las entidades financieras.
Otro caso es, típicamente,
alguien  de la familia va
y va la Expo Casa,
viene con una serie de ideas
y una serie de opciones
donde puede financiar su vivienda.
Pero ¿qué pasa? No puede comparar.
Resulta difícil establecer cuál
es la mejor opción si la A, la B o la C,
porque son tasas diferentes y condiciones
que tienen características
que las hacen distintas.
Entonces, hay un tema de cómo enfrentar
para tomar decisiones racionales
si la información no es comparable.
Tenemos también el caso típico.
A mí me llama un amigo y me dice
tomé un crédito y me están cobrando
una comisión por pagarlo antes de tiempo.
O bien hay una tasa piso y entonces
el consumidor enfrenta esas condiciones,
no las entiende, no las había previsto y
muchas veces no conoce la razonabilidad.
Por qué es que existen, y hay razones
por las cuales deben de existir.
Pero el consumidor o no las entiende,
o bien estas no tienen
los equilibrios necesarios.
El cuarto ejemplo, y yo estoy seguro
de que esto lo hemos vivido todos
y los que estamos en el sistema financiero
tanto dentro del sistema como viendo
lo que le pasa a las personas
que están afuera,
es el síndrome de las personas
sobre endeudadas.
Es el típico caso de una persona que
tiene múltiples deudas y que empieza
con problemas para poderlas servir.
En algunos casos son personas que
no logran tomar buenas decisiones
de cuándo y cómo consumir.
Es decir, no tienen en la racionalidad
que se supone que todos tenemos.
Y el otro caso, pues son personas
que tienen tragedias, problemas,
un divorcio, una enfermedad
que los lleva a un problema
donde no pueden pagar las deudas
y su ingreso no es suficiente.
Eso genera una serie de roces
entre el consumidor financiero
y las entidades que han dado los créditos.
Entonces, el sistema financiero enfrenta
estas circunstancias que muchas veces
no están debidamente atendidas
dentro del sistema,
son riesgos que no han sido
debidamente asumidos.
¿Qué hacer frente a estas circunstancias?
Pues hay diferentes cosas
que se pueden hacer.
Educación es una.
La otra es la regulación que algún ente
del Estado resuelva estos problemas.
Y la otra es que las mismas instituciones
hagan reglas, autodisciplina,
para enfrentar estas circunstancias
que podríamos llamar esas posibilidades
de las cáscaras de banano que enfrentan
los consumidores en su relación.
De estas tres, la que me interesa
más es la última.
De las otras dos ya se ha hablado más.
¿Qué es lo que, desde mi perspectiva,
deben hacer las entidades financieras?
En primer lugar, deben de tener
una cultura en todas sus instancias
para tratar y proteger al consumidor.
Esa relación de clientela
es una relación de largo plazo.
Hay que verla, no de corto plazo,
no el negocio que se hizo hoy,
sino que es el negocio
de toda la vida de una persona.
Y si eso se introduce
en el ADN de las entidades,
entonces van a tener que establecer
una cultura,  en la cual,
ese tema es tan importante
como cualquier otro tema
en la entidad financiera.
Eso implica que tiene que estar en todas
las instancias de las instituciones
desde los que toma las decisiones
arriba hasta el vendedor
y el que atiende al consumidor.
No es un tema de darle un cursito
de ventas a alguien,
sino que tiene que estar en toda
la institución y debe traducirse
en políticas explícitas, y además,
debe estar en la remuneración
de las personas.
El tema de que el consumidor tenga
salud financiera y que esté satisfecho
es un tema que ahí tiene que abordarse.
Desde luego que todo esto tiene
que traducirse en políticas explícitas,
políticas que tiene que ver
con dar adecuada información.
A veces no es dar tanta información,
sino transmitirla bien.
Eso hay que hacerlo y hay que
tener políticas sobre eso.
Hay que tener políticas del equilibrio
que tienen que tener las cláusulas
de los contratos de forma tal de que
el consumidor no se sienta,
que está en una posición de desventaja
y tiene que existir también
políticas explícitas para
evitar el sobreendeudamiento.
Esto puede ser que lo causen
otras entidades,
pero puede ser que mis clientes
lleguen a sobre endeudarse,
no por lo que yo haga,
sino por lo que hacen los demás.
Entonces tiene que administrarse
este riesgo porque es la salud financiera
del cliente en el largo plazo.
Y también instancias para que los clientes
puedan resolver sus conflictos
con las entidades financieras,
instancias que sean objetivas.
Por ejemplo, la Oficina del
Consumidor Financiero que estableció
la Asociación Bancaria es un mecanismo
de ese tipo, pero hay que desarrollarlo.
¿Para qué?
Para que esa relación
empiece a fluir de mejor forma,
para que esas cáscaras de banano
que pueden existir en el camino
sean cáscaras en las cuales
el consumidor no caiga.
Y porque si cae el consumidor, al final,
también la entidad financiera va a sufrir
en sus negocios de forma tal de que
es una mutua conveniencia.
Muchas gracias.